33 year old Anthony Mitchell of
hypothermia while in custody and it's
such a weird way for someone to in jail
that the physician who tried to treat
him said I'm not sure what circumstances
the patient was held in incarceration
but it is difficult to understand a
rectal temperature of 72 degrees
Fahrenheit while someone is incarcerated
in jail
told you you'd find this interesting
wild right
a normal rectal temperature is like 98.
if you don't understand like you guys
are like thinking like wait your insides
are never supposed to be that cold no
listen I'm I'm telling you if but right
for you this is an expertise my my dad
was a whole ass nurse so I could always
okay ask him questions about everything
everything that was like health related
I would ask him questions like for some
stupid reason I'm so dumb I I would like
butt stuff
and I'm the juvenile one right if I had
like must be butt stuff
they just take thermometers
ready your highness
friends Cuisine Don't Mind If I Do
but but I guess it's ready for them
for you to be considered like feverish
you don't need
to be it's not 10 degrees if you're if
you're at 37 degrees and that's your
normal or 36 right now
38 is a fever
that's two degrees
if your body temperature is two degrees
off
there's a big ass problem no pun
intended but there's a big problem like
if it's over if it's under this knob
that's not even it's not the fact it's
someone someone throws some [__] in your
ass
[Laughter]
somebody put the lunch in your booty
hole that [__] was so cold
I'm trying not to but I'm just saying
all right so let's find out what
happened how did this man die this way
and adding the cons of his hypothermia
is not clear it is possible he had an
underlying medical condition resulting
in hypothermia do not know if he could
have been exposed to a cold environment
but closing I do believe the hypothermia
was the ultimate cause of his death some
of that mystery is being figured out
after Mitchell's family filed a lawsuit
against jail officials and workers where
they're being alleged that Mitchell was
actually thrown naked into a walk-in
food freezer his punishment for giving
the officers a hard time and normally
you can just get out of those freezers
but reportedly Mitchell was strapped to
a restraining chair to keep him in place
and after hours there they finally got
him out and he was obviously
unresponsive with him then reportedly
dragging him naked throughout the jail
before putting him in a patrol vehicle
and driving him to the hospital and at
no point was an ambulance call and the
family apparently only knows so many of
these details because a hero officer at
the jail recorded the security footage
on her phone and handed it to the family
and this is a story that should matter
in general but one that also especially
matters with the United States
okay I had nothing to do with butt stuff
my bad
I want you guys to think about how
[__] up that is yeah that you are in a
jail and he puts you in a [__] crazy
freezer and you die of the Apple timer
you know what this is how normalized
this [__] is in my head
that's not even the [__] up part the
[__] up part is that somebody filmed
it put it out to the family yeah and she
was called a hero yeah that's what she's
supposed to do she did what police
officers should do which is take care of
crime and she was called a hero yep
these people killed this man because he
was giving them a hard time they threw
him in a freezer like it was a mafia
movie okay
and they murdered him
plain and simple
I mean sorry listen just because it's
not an oven or a gas chamber domain is
not deadly you guys would lose your
goddamn Minds if you knew it was a gas
Cape what's the difference I'm sorry but
just the idea the framing of this whole
story is already absurd enough as it is
but people think it's heroic for a cop
just to do the right thing which lets
you know the way people of you policing
officer work in general
telling the truth
abiding by your oath is heroic it's just
it's just interesting you know like if a
doctor Saves a Life nobody says here
he's a hero but that's his job but the
thing that happened is that the reason
why she's a hero is because
a man that was giving them a hard time
this is what they did to them
and that's our woman in the force
surrounded with men what are they going
to do to her if they find out that she's
snitching on them
that's why she's a hero not her knowing
all of this yeah knowing how these they
if they got caught this is not a first
appearance wait wait are you saying they
might go after her for snitching yes are
we talking about a criminal gang well
there's a Brotherhood you don't go
snitching on your people like that
her as a woman if she she would be done
up that's the reason why she is a hero
because she did all that thing and she
might have got caught today's video is
sponsored by surf shark no matter where
I'm at all right whether it's uh in my
house or in my Airbnb one on my way or
in Antarctica
or or even when I'm taking a [__] I need
to have access to all my programs hey
but sometimes the internet doesn't allow
me for that because it's restricted
because of the area that I'm in
yeah and for that I need a system that
allows me to change my location
and that's called a VPN changer yes and
a wonderful VPN that I'm using is surf
shark and it allows you to just change
the location of where you are and you
can watch everything that you want no
matter where you're at right now with
surf chart you can just use promo code
Abba and preach and you're gonna be able
to have 83 off plus there's a plus three
months extra free
I know crazy get on it the lawsuit filed
by his family today names the sheriff
and other Personnel at that jail CBS
42's Carly Lang's been going through
that lawsuit which includes some images
from inside the jail Carly in it you can
see Anthony Mitchell here in the orange
being carried by Personnel at the Walker
County Sheriff's Office his family who
calls him Tony told me he ended up in
the Walker County jail after they called
for a welfare check tonight there's a
lot of outrage about this video and the
images that have come to light because
of the family's lawsuit we have that
right here as CBS 42 reported last week
this video contradicts the statement we
received from The Walker County
Sheriff's Office about Tony Mitchell's
condition when he left the jail that
statement reads in part quote the inmate
was alert and conscious when he left the
facility and arrived at the hospital now
as you can see in this video before
before I even give you guys any of my
opinions I just want you guys to
appreciate the only reason this got out
is because one of the other officers
told the truth about what had happened
meaning all those live all those
officers committed perjury and lied
about what had happened
they all lied about it and they it was
the conspiracy a very real one in which
they all forged a story in order to
cover their own asses and only another
officer willing to put themselves at
risk made this thing happen imagine all
the times where this doesn't happen if
these guys threw this guy in for just
being a disobedient person they threw in
the freezer just for being disobedient
imagine what else these guys have done
because you know it ain't their first
time considering how many people die in
jail in police custody okay
do you truly believe this is their first
time potentially killing somebody the
way that they so effortlessly lie in all
Health covered up do you think it's
their first time
mind you these are not violent criminals
when you're put in jail there's not a
prison this is jail
this is sometimes where you get held
when you don't have bond to be even go
to court there's sometimes where you go
when you have a DUI that sometimes where
you go when you're under suspicion of
certain things
this is a jail not prison you know what
they say if you have nothing to be
afraid just don't resist and go with the
officer
this is what happens at that place
so appreciate the fact that this is a
story but it's actually an indication of
a larger issue was a bigger issue that
cops are human
yeah they are
they are human
yup very much human
as much as there are people in in
business places that have power trips
they have Power Trip they actually have
powers [__] they got guns
yeah
the truth is done
more and more things like that are
coming out
Anthony Tony Mitchell appears limp and
unconscious claims made in this lawsuit
give a closer look at what his family
believes happened to him during his two
weeks in the Walker County Jail that's
where he had been in custody since his
arrest on January 12th according to
court documents Mitchell froze to death
the lawsuit states he arrived at the
hospital with a body temperature of 72
degrees and this lawsuit claims Mitchell
was likely placed in a restraint chair
in the jail kitchen's walk-in freezer or
similar environment and left there for
hours this lawsuit also details graphic
and disturbing details about Tony's last
days of Life claiming he was tased
neglected put in a freezer and left for
dead as officers and staff ignored his
medical needs now screenshots from jail
surveillance video show Mitchell on the
floor naked in what appears to be an
office that suit claims Mitchell was
left for five hours as numerous
Corrections Officers and medical staff
quote wandered over to his open cell
door to spectate and be entertained by
his condition in quote now that suit
also Praises The Bravery of a
corrections officer who has since been
fired for taking the video and sharing
it hold on do you see what the [__] I
was telling you disgusting when I told
you the reason why she was called a hero
this might be one of the most disgusting
things I've seen cops do but do you know
you understand now they spectated while
this man was freezing yeah but like he
was a piece of steak that they pulled
out of the freezer and watched thaw
disgusting now do you understand why I
said she was a hero because she lost her
job and I want y'all to appreciate this
is a wrongful death lawsuit meaning
there may not even be charges pressed
against any of these [__] despicable
people no no and the person the person
that actually said something lost their
job did you hear that [__] bruh now you
understand why I say that [__] so the
person that actually did the right thing
that actually went there sacrificed a
whole lot and that's that's we don't
even know if her uh her life is going to
be in Jeopardy these people are not
going to do something to her whenever
she's going to be outside or whatever
whatnot you know how it is gangs moving
gangs you know what I mean so and she
that person lost their job why did they
lose their job why because they just
they didn't go through protocol and they
didn't they didn't uh they didn't go
through uh the supervisor to give well
you know this is a problem this is
happening no you went the other route
you're gonna lose your job but they're
not even probably not even going to be
charged bro Hey listen so so yeah listen
yeah she's a hero anytime y'all here to
protect and serve you ask yourself who
who I've been saying that
and don't get me wrong there's people in
these positions who want to do the right
thing but that's not their work maybe
maybe they do and they get fired or
maybe they can't because if they do
they'll get ostracized or maybe they'll
end up in the freezer next but so you
have to understand it ain't even a
matter of every individual involved it's
about the whole apparatus as a whole it
is
about to to function in a
self-preservation manner and that's
against the benefits of the people it's
supposed to serve so when I watched it
hey man y'all try to tell me that ain't
one of the most disgusting things I've
ever heard they put this man in the
freezer like a mafia movie that's crazy
and they watch them and they enjoyed it
they were entertained that's crazy yeah